because Gaza is a guarantee that they're
going to end up dying the same thing's
going to happen
again I'll be honest with you what uh
breathtaking it leaves one speechless I
mean you just look and be like is this
coming from this little girl I mean
she's asking some logical
questions by the grace of Allah subhah
wa tala the response has been
overwhelming to say the very least
alhamdulillah we've had social media
personalities and respected Scholars sh
from many parts of the Muslim world
promoting the cause we have raised
almost 1.4 million alhamdulillah and we
haven't been sitting idy waiting to hit
our Target of 2 million we have fully
purchased four properties in London
transferred their ownership to the W
after the help of Allah subhanahu wa
tala none of this would be possible
without your support so we thank you
once again this is our update to
yourselves we encourage you to stay
tuned for more updates now that the work
alhamdulillah is truly
underway brothers and sisters and dear
friends when I saw this video of this
young girl she looks like she's three or
four years old and Subhan Allah like I
was looking and thinking this is not the
speech of a child it's not the speech of
a child it's coming from a child but
this cannot be the speech of a child the
articulation the tone the the the mercy
that the way she just talks like you
know we need to know when someone's
talking from the heart and someone
that's speaking the H somebody that is
speaking the truth you just like you
know you know I was just amazed I was
absolutely amazed obviously we're going
to watch the video of the two absolute
um genocide Pro genocidal Maniacs that's
what they are for that matter okay
that's what they are for that matter
they have turned the Gaza into a retail
like they're you know uh planning on you
know doing stuff selling Etc you know
andd you know what it is like to me it's
just like bro I just cannot wait I just
cannot wait till the day of judgment you
know do you really believe if that God
exists we believe that God exists for
those who do know but do you really be
really believe that that God the god of
Christianity or Judaism or Hinduism
whatever they deem God to be we don't
deem that to be God do you really
believe that God because we believe God
has is ultimately perfect maximally
perfect he's the most trust do you
really believe God is going to be like
yeah these people are my people and they
are going to paradise and the Guardians
are going Hellfire this a great
Injustice let's watch the video first of
um this uh Trump is a trump actually not
Trump yes and this other Satan yahu
inshah discussing casually turning Gaza
into a reto him I think that Gaza maybe
is a demolition site right now if you
look at Gaza it's all I mean there's
hardly a building standing and the ones
that are are going to collapse you can't
live in Gaza right now and I think we
need another location I hope that we
could do something where they wouldn't
want to go back who would want to go
back they've experienced nothing but
death and destruction if we can get a
beautiful area to resettle people
permanently in nice homes and where they
can be happy and not be shot not be
killed not be knifed to death like
what's happening in Gaza and nobody can
live there you can't live there so if we
can build if we can build them through a
massive amounts of money supplied by
other people very rich Nations uh and
they'll they're willing to supply it
because Gaza is a guarantee that they're
going to end up dying the same thing's
going to happen again it's happened over
and over again and it's going to happen
again and then let's hear the voice of a
real this this little girl is more of a
man this little girl has more honor more
dignity more heart than these men and
their Nations the governments put
together I'm not talking about the
innocent people who are free from this
because are many Americans um Israelis
yes who are against what these
individual doing okay I'm not talking
about Zionist there's Jews out there who
are Christians out there who speak
against their thing here's the video
Let's watch
it
for Fore
oh I mean guys I I I'll be honest with
you what uh
breathtaking I mean it leaves one
speechless I mean you just look and be
like this is this coming from this
little girl I mean she's asking some
logical questions with this basic
logical questions you can see and that's
the reason why people's hearts around
the world are with Gaza yes they have
got every everyone in servitude to
Israel except Gaza they've got everyone
bowing down except Gaza and Gaza is
going to win and Gaza is winning in the
pr level public opinion people coming to
Islam people sympathizing more people
seeing the reality of Zionism and their
connections to all other atrocities that
have been happening all around the world
yes I don't want to go to details yeah
the whole entire world Israel has lost
this battle on all grounds they've lost
the the battle ATT against the
resistance that the UN says that the
Palestinians have a right to
self-determination and defense you know
they've losted against that and the
public been change so much soul that
they trying to get rid of Tik Tok and
this and that and the anti that they
throw left and right it's not working
and I found this amazing I just want to
share and end on with a couple of vers
in the Quran Allah says in the
Quran for
[Music]
one of my favorite verses in the Quran
Allah says the reward of an evil deed is
its equivalent but whoever Pardons and
seeks reconciliation then their reward
is with Allah he certainly does not like
the wrongdoers there is no blame on
those who enforce Justice after being
wronged blame is only on those who wrong
people and transgress in the land
unjustly it is they who will suffer a
painful punishment and whoever endures
patiently and forgives surely this is a
resolve to Aspire to that is one verse
in the Quran alhamdulillah and Allah
says and what is it with you you do not
fight in the cause of Allah and for the
oppressed men women children who cry out
our Lord Deliver us out of this land of
oppressors I point for us a savior I
point for us a helper all by your grace
Ina verse 9 if I'm not mistaken not
verse 75 alhamdulillah yeah brothers and
sisters this little girl's message is
something that brings chills down the
spine of those who truly understand she
speaks the H with her little tone with a
cute little self may Allah subhana tala
let this be recorded in history that her
speech against two oppressors who are
trying to after ethnically cleans it
trying to defitely cleanse these people
now they're trying to come with this
false notion of oh we don't want them to
get harmed and there's bombs and this
that yous you zims your day is going to
come Allah says in the Quan the
Believers are going to be on reclining
chairs looking on and seeing if the evil
doers have been paid for what they used
to deny and we will see that inshah and
the Muslims will have the last love
believe me that God Almighty is the most
just and that day is going to come they
are going to to pay for it bit by bit
inch by inch they are going to suffer
the consequences inshallah and hope we
live to see in this life or in Hereafter
so next time